the browns now that they've gotten
things under control they've got a coach
that has elevated the franchise much
more than
than uh
freddie kitchen's ever could and kevin
stefanski what do they do
to take it from final eight
to final four final two
i think i look at their offense and go
love it
don't really need to do jack diddley
squat on that side of the ball
you know they got receivers they got
tight ends they got one of the best
offensive lines in football they got the
best running back combo in football i
mean geez they got you know two of the
top ten running backs in football on the
same team i mean it's it's remarkable i
think when i look at them it's defense
defense defense and the first place i
look at
is linebacker and you know we've heard
the the recent rumors right about
levante david a little bit there and
it's something again we hit on the
podcast to me that's where it's it's
gotta start that defense that's a
seattle scheme joe woods their defensive
coordinator who i got tremendous respect
for he was down in tampa when i was
there you know hey listen the seattle
scheme came from tampa too it's all the
same coaching tree it's all those guys
what do they believe in they believe in
derrick brooks and bobby wagner's and
you know we saw miles jack down in
jacksonville they run that defense the
chargers drafted last year the kid
kenneth murray from oklahoma the 49ers
run that scheme oh there's fred warner
they missed they have none of that uh
linebacker for the cleveland brows
that to me would be the first thing to
really make that scheme go you need some
dudes to play linebacker and then off of
that you know the the safety safety
position i think has got to be a big
upgrade too because again as we we can
talk about those defenses the derwyn
james the cam chancellors right those
type of guys uh jamal adams up in
seattle now they make that defense go
too the earl thomases so it to me is
more about that it's that center part of
their defense at the second and third
level that they really don't have any
big time difference makers they got a
lot of money and i would think they're
going to be able to spend and improve
that part of their football team and
watch out for cleveland if they do
they were interested in jj watt
by all accounts right ports von miller
if he becomes available is that a guy
that you think they should pursue i i do
yes for the right price yes i mean
olivier vernon is a free agent right i i
i i so i don't know where that goes but
you know again it's another scheme as
you hit on it you know it's great point
i'm glad you led me there it's about
pass rushers right joey bosa ingram you
know all the pass rushers the seattle
seahawks have of course the 49ers going
back to that story again with their bosa
and they got d ford when they went to
the super bowl and that that it's a
scheme that really wants to rush for
drop seven and they have their creative
ways to play their seattle scheme and do
all that type of stuff and they can let
those guys just fly around so
i would think yes that after that
linebacker safety issue
that's the next thing they look at can
we get another guy
that okay if you're always going to
worry about miles garrett well okay
you're you're not going to just get off
you know scot-free on the other side
with just some nobody who can't get
after the quarterback and i think you
know really we kind of hit it right
there i think it's those three positions
you hit on can really really skyrocket
them to one of the the best teams in the
afc
i remember when i pointed out in 2018
that there was a push in the front
office by some to take bradley chubb
instead of denzel ward could you imagine
bradley oh my gosh
okay baby i mean that would be yes that
would be scary and they gotta go nothing
against denzel ward no nothing gets
denzel he's really good pass rush that
makes a defense go he is and then and
that
and that scheme which they weren't doing
at the time when they did that draft i
think if they could do it over they
would because in that scheme you don't
necessarily need shut down man-to-man
corners all the time you know it's it's
a zone defense that's what it is
denzel ward is really good if they could
get damn greedy williams to stay healthy
from lsu he's a perfect scheme fit for
that defense defense too so they got
talent there uh but both of those guys
have had issues staying healthy and
that's something they might have to get
some death depth behind them as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports